GREAT TO SEE BYRON RETURNING.
>> Dave: HE WILL BRING SO
JAKE BEAN A PART OF THAT
EQUATION AS WELL.
>> Dave: THIS IS INTERESTING.
WILL THEY LOOK TO REVIEWING ROS,
IN TRANSITION, SHOT, SCORES!MON.
UP NEAR THE SHOULDER THERE,
COULD NOT TO PUSH THAT ONE ACROS
AND LOOK OUT,
SHOT THAT BEAT HIM, 9:49 OF THEE
AND THEN GAVE IT AWAY TO
ROBINSON WITHRTS THAT PLAY NOW O
CLAGUE.
THIS TIME, IT IS CLAGUE, RIGHT
ON THE STII
WON A STANLEY
CUP BEFORE SIGNING WITH MONTREAT
TIME AND TOOK THE PUCK AWAY A
HERE, TO PUCK NOW. THEM GOING.E.
SHOOTS.N AND HERE TO
WERENSKI.
>> Bryan: THIS IS LEHKONEN IN,
SHOT, SCORES!
AND A PICKOFF THERE.GHT
THERE.
IS SILLINGER, WITH JENNER, SHOT,
E, A TWO-ON-ONE,
SILLINGER,  AND THIS IS ANDERSO,
A SHOT
GOAL SCORERS, THEY LIKE THOSE
EMPTY NETS.